who knows what the rafale is
raise your hand
oh that's actually pretty pretty cool
okay so you shouldn't talk at all i
think
uh because i'm not gonna say anything
you i suppose
um probably start with demos right away
okay so
the biggest problem with raphael is the
fact that people
usually have no idea what to do with it
before i say what it is usually people
say oh it's a nice toy
it's nice it's cool good for charts
and then just think okay so what could i
do about charts
so i can show you some examples i did
recently so this is a sketchy like
application i did with raphael i did as
a side project at my current job uh
we have like a code review tool and we
would like to add something like picture
review so you could
drop some pictures and somebody could
you know come here and say like hey look
at this guy
and then just oh like don't look here
and uh oh that's that's kind of nice
head
and they're like ah sorry i'm just need
to it's like this yeah
sorry it's all this very editable
all this semi-transparent and
and so on and so forth this is like one
of use cases how you could use this
vector graphic stuff so raphael is for
vector graphics i forgot to say that
if you haven't heard about drive plus
vector graphics now the animation
what's the vector graphics or graphics
library without good animation
this actual demo from the site so not
really new if you've already been on the
on the website so the idea that
as soon as you create any object in
raphael be it circle rectangle or
custom shape you could then change the
attributes
and change it field change its stroke
change it
something else there are lots of
attributes i'll talk about it later a
bit
and of course you could change it
instantly or you could change it all the
time
so for example you could change the
coordinates of the circle and
feel all the time like this it's
pretty kind of cool thing
and uh you could change the rotation of
the ellipse you could change the
rotation of the rectangle
uh you could change path into another
path
so you could grab one path and animate
it to another path
along the time did they say it works in
a6
it works in i6 and uh an i7 yeah and i
ate
an i9 in safari firefox opera
chrome okay it's about chrome anyway
and it's not real morphing
if you think that this is real morphing
it's not real morphing it depends where
the
coordinates is started so it just
basically turns from one path into
another
so for example in this rectangle
transforming to
triangle it's not really nice looking
morphing animation
this looks much better here and the only
difference in that
the first rectangle drawn from the left
top corner and the
bottom rectangle is drawn from the right
top corner to make things a bit more
smoother
but if you put the points in correct way
on the path
then animation is really smooth like for
this circle
or for this circle basically the first
circle has
three points and the first circle has
four points that's why animation is so
smooth if you have different
points it's not really as smooth so it's
quite stupid animation
uh the way it could be used could be
used for example for the
these sort of charts uh to do the
animation on the fly
as soon as you create a new object you
control any of these parameters
and for example you could when you
create a curve you could basically
control the curve
and change it the way you wish and
it's very very dynamic and stuff
now the other way to use like this is
something i saw on bespin project and
saying oh that's a cool idea i should
probably
try to create a demo which looks alike
and i
kind of show this demo on our homepage
so when you
when you edit the page you could say
okay now i want to add the comment to
the page
so you just click anywhere and you have
a menu pops up
and you could choose okay when i had
comment and something will happen
or you say okay i want to favorite this
page and favorite this page
so again the difference between these
and canvas
is that this actually also works naive
the same way
you could use the gradients in rafael
as well as anything else there are some
limitations i will talk about it later
okay let's back to our
presentation now when i show it
right so this is raphael this is a
graphic library written in javascript
and you could use javascript to create
graphical stuff
and rafael provides you the adapter to
make it work across
all the browsers i'm aware of
so how is it done well
first of all how it was created a bit of
history sort of
it was created because i'm stupid uh
i was working on the project for we have
like a hack day
in atlassian the company i'm working for
and i need to create something to
impress
java developers uh in the company
and because they're java developers they
have no idea about javascript so you
can't impress it with some just
something
i should create something visual you
know so they could ask how the fact you
did it
so i was thinking oh yeah we'll create
some chatting so i pick out the dojo gfx
and start
taking on dojo gfx trying to draw some
stuff
i spent one hour and didn't succeed even
to draw a circle and i just said okay
i'm just idiot i can't find
how this api works i just draw myself
whatever
and i start hacking on with svg and
vml so basically it's svg
i choose svg because i first of all i
was using svg back in 2001 and i kind of
like it
and svg is cool and scg support is kind
of getting there
the only one problem with svg of course
and you know i wouldn't say how much i
hate explorer because it's kind of
understandable but believe me guys i
hate it a bit more than you
because you probably most of you
probably never actually work with this
monster
the bml is the grandfather of svg it was
created by microsoft and
visio guys to probably as i assume
so when you save to web from microsoft
word all your charts
all you you know lines and curves and
shapes will also be saved and you could
view them in
explorer so they come with the standard
for vector graphics which is pretty good
in the in the in the idea
they submitted to w3cw3c rejected it
but they like the idea so they create
svg based on vml
and microsoft actually take a part in
the creating of svg but for some reason
they decide not to put it into their
browser and
come with their professor is standard
which is obviously cooler yeah
it's like email
vml an svg shares the same idea
you could create objects in the page
just like you create divs you create
circles rectangles curves whatever
and that's it that's as simple as it is
now vml svg is just two
different apis to kinda the same sort of
engine
vml api is a piece of sheet
right it's smoking stinky piece of
but as soon as you use svg and vml
together
you could make all these guys happy and
they could all show you the same circle
kind of the same way not guaranteed
pixel perfect
but depends how you wrote it
and please note mobile safari here
so svg supported in
touch whatever i bought a
ipad iphone since 2.2
software update so basically everywhere
now to make these two these two things
are way different
like really different like totally
different
the api is so different svg in vml
and the only way i found to make them
all together is javascript
so i create a javascript layer which did
detect the feature do you support svg
the browser or support vml and
use the different methods to creating
the
stuff now this is how it looks like in
the coverage of the features
the svg is a bit bigger than vml
vmware is a bit smaller now the raphael
trying to cover something it could cover
everywhere
so it doesn't cover all the svg and
doesn't cover all the vml
but it cover big enough chunk of
functionality to create
something useful when people come
complaining about hey the svg had this
awesome feature like clipping puff
could you put it in rafael
you could put it in rafael it's open
source project as soon as you make it
work
in explorer i'll be happy absolutely i
have no idea how to build a rafael how
to make it work in vml
i mean if you can awesome submit the
patch i will apply
g now uh
raphael is 20 kilobytes zipped
and minified so it's kind of small
now as i say can you do the charts as
usual thing it's like people like oh
yeah awesome i could use it for charts
yeah you can use it for charts it's not
only for charts
you just saw this product called
presentation like
i don't know forty percent of a ui
interface
elements could be done with raphael like
all this
attached to the anchor so yeah you could
do it with images
but with images it will be like okay you
have like five images five gtp requests
all these are stiff can stiff here okay
svg will be much faster for one
javascript file
right which contains all this stuff and
most of the time actually
the svg is smaller than the image unless
it's
you know photo of your wife or something
like that
so wait where it could be used the first
and
obvious example is raphaelgs home site
uh i did the redesign recently and i
create all these images
for the icons i draw it myself so i
don't need to pay anybody
so i'm sorry if it's ugly uh i draw
these icons and
make an amazing logo by the sub cube
but i found that i have too much http
requests and my
rafael gs has about 2 000 hits per day
which is not big
for some corporate website but it's
pretty big for open source library
which is a special target so it has like
lots of hits so i decided okay i could
use sprites
i'm smart i read the books so i was
i was using sprites and still it was
like
not good enough so i think oh well it's
these icons are pretty simple i could
draw them in raphael i draw them in
vector in the beginning
so i draw them on in raphael so now i
cut another http request because it's
just in my javascript
and it's actually smaller than the
images
and so all this stuff
all this stuff are not images
this screenshot contains no images at
all
right so there are like
three files html css and javascript
that's that's all well the page down
there has one image more but this part
doesn't have any
how cool is that now i i'll quickly show
you
why this matter actually
this matter because this is a page
right this is how it looks now let's
zoom it
right because it's not an image
it's zooming really nice and
you'll be surprised but it's printing
also very nice
when you print it the logo and the icons
looks like it's not from the page like
it's come from pdf or something
if i bring it up like hang you the
printout you will never believe it's
printed from the web page
because it's vector in explorer it works
the same way
so it's not just uh
so size does matter
your icons or your logo like if you have
a logo of yours
of your company on the page creating
recreating the logo with raphael doesn't
only make it smaller
it also make it print nicely and
particularly know about the guys who was
using raphael for the application
because they have to print it and they
have to have a pie chart
and because you know you work with a
client and client
usually is not technical person which we
call just dumb
right so he says like oh i printed up it
looks pixelated
but wtf it's a image you know the dpi of
the screen is not
actually as good as dpi of the printer
like what we can do like
i don't know it's pixelated make it look
nice
so they pick up the rafael and draw the
same pie chart with raphael
bring it up everybody is happy looks
awesome on print
so if you have any icons in your page
like like icons on the left is
rafael icons icon on the right as images
when you zoom them up the difference is
stunning
and printing could be very important
could be really a killer i remember when
i was developing the application and
it could be printed so i have to include
another huge
chip file with the logger and resize it
to make it small
and hide it with css and open it with a
print so it
will print it biggest image which is
zoomed out so it will be nice on the
print
and i always feel guilty because i put
the extra
you know image for the user to download
just in case he will print
now you don't need to worry about this
just make it to this rafael it
works and it prints nicely
the other user like ui interface
things you could use rafale for like for
example for something like this
that's actually live example from one of
my current projects
we have this pop-up appears on the page
and you know like in
any middle to big company we have a
developer we have a designer and we have
a
manager right and uh
manager says hey we need pop-up designer
said awesome
rounded corners so i come to design and
say hey okay
rounded corners let's talk do you really
need rounded corners
like all around the corners also like do
you really really need rounded corners
well okay ie could be without one okay
fine
i make it with css awesome now okay and
now
this little pixie on the top will be
awesome it'll tweak it to show where you
are okay
pixie okay i draw the image in photoshop
put it in make it look like this awesome
then it was day of review so me manager
and designer sit together and i show
them okay that's how it looks like
they're like oh looks pretty nice is it
isn't the frame too dark making make it
lighter
okay yeah give me like i don't know 10
minutes i have to redraw it and
you know photoshop the image i have to
upload it
i have to build the package run the
application and then come back together
and i will say could you just play with
fire but no i can't play with firebug
sorry
i couldn't change the background now i
can't change the background like again
tell me
come on so
i have free time i
delete all this code and replace this
thing with rafael
the next review was so much smoother
rounded corner is a bit bigger yeah big
smaller yeah does it work with explorer
like this yeah it works explorer has it
around the corners in explorer yes
around the corners and explorer
the most complicated path part was to
draw a shape like this
i should say it's not the most
complicated task i ever had so
i successfully achieve it
so rafael in the ui for ui elements
could make your
ui more flexible could make your code
smaller
because if you have similar ui elements
with different color
for example you could easily achieve it
theming the ui
easily achievable you don't need to
create five different images for
gradient background for five different
themes
what else you could do that's a risk
game
i started to develop but i was too lazy
to finish
i make it work so you click on the on
the country it creates the arrows where
you want to attack you click country one
attack they
bump to each other and but then they
always bore it and they just
the rules are too complicated the
javascript is easy so
but you can do stuff like that you can
do it with these this is very small and
if you look at the footprint of this
page
it's tiny it's tiny
because it has no images again
and just one javascript file
the another another another unexpected
usage
for the raphael we found in our
applications
this page also contain no images as i
told right so
this shadow is real shadow it's
semi-transparent so it
it's on gray background you can't really
appreciate it but if you have
text on the background or anything it's
semi-transparent shadow the shadow done
with raphael
and shadow down with gradients from
black to transparent
and we were using this shadow now in our
products
why because the size of the images to
create the shadow
is about 100 kilobyte the size of
raphael library 20 kilobyte
which means even even if you use rough
rail just for this shadow and nothing
else for the project
it's already worthwhile not mentioned
that rafael is again just one http
request
and for images you have like what eight
http requests
you can't really sprite them so
that's a win-win and yeah it works an
explorer without
you know dancing and shaking and in e6 i
mean
semi-transparent shadow
another small example it's the table
which exists in the results of some web
development
survey and the javascript enhance the
table by adding the
charting to it this html table
and underneath of html table if
javascript is on we're adding the chart
using raphael to make it
you know much a bit easier readable
thing
just an enhancement to existing again
it's very nicely when when
people need to print it it prints very
nice
you have very nice printing outfit
now as soon as we are at the geeky
conference
i can talk about geeky stuff
okay
i was struggling with animation when i
did animation first time i had a problem
after a while i've noticed that if you
have
like this this is in this test i create
like i don't know about
200 circles draw them in the
in the line with the cycle and then i
decide okay now all these circles
animate to
a particular x so they should all
you know come to the one line and i
noticed that a
because the it takes a while to animate
each circle
then when you come to the last circle
the time is different and the position
is different so they're not moving as a
whole line but instead they moving like
yogi and the verse is browsed as a jog
and explorers are just going like this
and then coming to the line at the end
because they first of all they don't
have the same timer each of them has a
separate timer
and second because uh
i say animate it means which means i go
through all of them and say animate
animate animate animate
so when i come to this guy in the middle
i say animate
the start of animation is different from
the guy in the beginning because some
time has passed
when i counted it so i add another
method animate with and if you have
objects in the group and say animate
they all animate with that never happens
like you have a frame you have a text
you animate and text goes you know
following the frame
so this is a
original video how it was you could see
how jog it is
and then after update it's run very
smooth
it's very rock solid line
i'm gonna be proud of this
thanks i know i know somebody will
appreciate it one day
okay in in the recent release
people start complaining that in
explorer the
quality of the graphics of the shapes is
a bit dodgy
you could see the shapes on the left
while you could see they're not as good
as shape on the right
there's some problems like here
they're like some problem with the dot
with the question mark it's not really
there they're like one pixel differences
here and there
which could be very annoying why it
happens because vml is awesome api
right in vml when you specify the path
you can't specify
you could only specify integer values
for pixels
in in svg you could specify you know
pixels for floating point numbers
so for vml i have to round them
the problem with rounding is of course
sometimes one pixel is not much
but sometimes half pixel is a lot
this exact examples of that if you have
small shapes like this 32 by 32 icons
you could see they are dodgy on the left
they are not
really as smooth so what i did
at the end because vml can draw
with half pixels it's vector engine
it's just api it's totally
so i draw the image when you create a
path i draw image like 10 times bigger
and then
zoom it in with vml internal features to
zoom it
down 10 times and then i have precision
not 1 pixel but 1 10th of pixel which is
kinda enough for everybody for so far if
it will be enough i will make it
100 times bigger and then zoom it 100
times but 10 times it's good enough
and then on the right you could see the
icons i compare it with a
like firefox rendering it's pretty much
the same
so i'm pretty happy with that so this is
like in the latest rafale 1.3.2
and rafael 1.3.3 is on my laptop
waiting for be released
by the way the whole raphael was written
on the train
i have very long connection from gok
from home to work it's one hour
so it's like wasting what two hours per
day so i bought the laptop
and the whole raphael pretty my hundred
percent was written on the train
on this particular device
so and as i said it works on iphone
oh sorry on ipad
right it doesn't work on android
because android guys doesn't include svg
support in their webkit
i would i wouldn't i wouldn't i wouldn't
comment on this just
i don't know
i haven't write a line of code to make
rafael works on iphone
as soon as uh as soon as os 2.2 was
released for iphone
rafael just magically started working
there
that's the power of web standards
because when it's about svg rafael
relies on web standards
that's it when it's about vml
it relies on microsoft implementation of
vml
because don't be mistaken the vml
specification
despite written totally by microsoft and
vml implementation internet explorer are
two different things
like if you read msdn i think that's how
things are that's not how things are
right there are lots of bugs in
like microsoft live bugs i think they
just love insects in general it's like
they
they create the api they document it and
they're like oh come on guys let's go
boring let's add some bugs
they hit some bugs nobody stop them from
implementing them
totally because it's like you know i
wrote it i implemented like
why i should make bugs anyway anyway
anyway
api i think api is most important part
of any javascript library
that's probably why jquery is so popular
i don't want to offend victoria but i
don't think it's like the greatest
library ever
but i think that api is very
sweet and that's why it's so great
not because it's great library i mean
it's good library
but because api is so good that's why
it's so popular that's why
you know you can't compete with chick
very much so i spend a lot of time on
thinking about api
and as soon as i talk about jquery i
just
you know i just steal it from jquery
i chat with john he's okay
so how to create uh stuff in raphael
so first of all when you want to draw
something you have to create canvas
not bad canvas okay not html5 cannot i
like this
like we are smart people okay why are we
giving dumb names to the products
the prototype javascript library the
closure javascript library
the canvas dammit
now i can't talk about canvas without
confusing people it's not canvas it's
not html5 canvas
it's kind of a canvas you know canvas
people drawing on you know canvas
i call it paper okay
so you need to create a paper to draw on
it's very simple there are three ways to
create the paper
paper jesus first way you write raphael
and put
the three parameters the id of a
placeholder
some div for example and dimensions
within height
second very end you put the actual dom
element placeholder
and within height and the third variant
you put top left within height
depends what is most suitable for you
then as soon as you create a paper you
can draw
on the paper what you can draw you can
draw primitives
of course you could draw a circle
you could draw a rectangle and you could
draw ellipse this is
primitives and if you're in difference
to canvas api i actually include circle
function
so be thankful for the circle you
specify
coordinates of the center and the radius
for the rectangle specify
x and y within height and optional
radius of the corners
by the way in vml when you specify the
radius
of the corner you specified
the value of radius is the percentage
from the shortest side of the rectangle
that's very convenient indeed
so it's not a pixel like if you specify
everything pixels
and in an svg specified in pixel and in
roughly specifying pixels
in vml it's percentage of the shortest
side of the rectangle
for whomever it could be convenient i
have no idea
so rafael take care of this and
fortunately not on the base
and as soon as you create a element
in primitive in this case as you see you
are
it to the to the object to the variable
then this object the primitive is a
wrapper
object around the actual presentation
svg or vml in the browser
and you could access the actual dom
element
by saying circle.node or rec.node
i would recommend you to do this only if
you really know what you're doing
because svg and vml are so way different
so if you decide to write your program
cross browser
think twice before accessing dot node
but i give you this
option whatever each
each element has a set of
methods the thing you can do with it
so you could animate you could animate
along some paths you could animate on
some path different direction you could
animate with another element
you could set attributes and the
attributes is probably the most
useful method so you could set and get
attributes from the element
you could attach uh event handlers like
click on mouse
mouse down mouse move mouse out and so
far and so forth and
so and so
so example uh we create a circle then
say circle.rttr
and you specify the objects which have a
uh attributes for the circle
the attributes that just take from svg
specification
so if you know svg it should be very
clean for you what to do if you don't
know svg you could always read the svg
spec
i mean it's kind of self-explanatory
the feel is feel and the stroke is
stroke color so as raphael supports not
only hexa
hexadecimal representation of the color
but also rgb
and i also include hsb hue saturation
brightness because it's kind of
awesome to have
and stroke weights could be variety it's
also only pixels and opacity is from
zero to one
you also could specify all the
parameters like
cx ui and radios in fact you could
create circle without parameters at all
you could just say
create circle with bracket bracket and
let's say
rttr and put all the attributes there
you could grab attributes by specifying
it as a string
and obviously you could animate when you
animate the first parameter is also
the same attribute object so this is
attributes where you wanna
object have after the animation not all
attributes are animatable
it's kind of obvious and you could have
a milliseconds you have obviously call
back
and you could have easing and you could
create your own heating
if you don't like the existing easy so
the attributes exist on the
all the objects all the elements are
based
of course some of them are only make
sense for some elements like
crc have only sensed for images
font only have stands for text
uh target the target makes sense for
everything
so you could add a href for any element
make it a hyperlink
you could add rotation the path only
makes sense for path
so i had this word puff how do you
english speaker pronounce this
but it's it's when you you could create
different
custom paths and that's uh the most
powerful thing about raphael
so the path syntax is very simple
you say paper the path and put the path
string
easy the example of past string
it's very simple actually
it's right it's right from svg
so i like it's like
not rocket science really i'll tell you
i'll explain it a bit
it's actually much simpler than it looks
so
it's all in svg's pack and you could
read it if you want to write it by hand
but basically the whole string contains
of commands and parameters for the
commands
so each letter is a command all the
numbers comma separated
of space separated after the letter are
parameters of the command
as easy as that so this is a command
in this case it's move so we move our
pen to the particular particular
x and y this is x
this is and this is why
so capital letters means it's absolutely
moving lowercase letters means it's
relatively moving
so you have here you have moved to x y
then
draw a relative line to x y draw another
relative line to x y and so on and so
forth
nobody asked you to read them so let
let me show you some demo of actually
the usage of bosses
uh
i have this pdf file on the screen
it has a very recognizable icon right
so let's uh open it with my
favorite vector driving probe so this is
vector icon for
of firefox logger simplifies
just for sake of this demo now let's
save it
scg right
okay now
this is a test html this is a small html
i wrote just for for this demo
so it's basically just html which
contains rafael
gs include and then some javascript
which unload
draw raphael paper and then
i will draw some paths here
let's find this file and
this is fire for just opening
right so you can see here this is funky
path has already encoded here
so you don't need to write it by hand
unless you're crazy
or just like pain i don't know but
you could just grab it from illustrator
or inkscape or any vector
any vector tool that supports
that supports a svg
which is pretty much everything so it
add all the information here so give me
the feel
color i could easily put this fill color
here
now if i say this
that's what i got right
how easy was that so i have this path
right here
it's vector zooming you want to do
something cool about it okay let's do
something cool about it i don't know
that's that's animated
i don't know
something like this something you
probably can't do with the images right
so it's just a short demo over there
it's like don't be scared by this
path syntax because most of the time you
don't really need to use them
but sometimes like when i draw the when
if i just need to draw the little twixie
not the whole thing then drawing tweaks
you i could
draw it of course with the string
methods instead of
creating it in illustrator or something
now obviously each good library
need plugins
and you can create plugins for rafael as
well
so again i steal the syntax from jquery
so you could write raphael.the fan arrow
and that's mean that paper object will
have the arrow method now
and inside the arrow method this is
actually paper
so it will be run in context of the
paper and you could draw some custom
you know custom shape here for example
if you need to use this arrow all the
time
you just create a method and then just
use paper.arrow
you could also add customer methods to
the elements then you write raphael.l
and i create for example shortcut for
field and stroke instead of
using httr all the time so that makes
just your development a bit easier or
you could create some raffle and pub
rafale plugin and publish it there are
some plugins
i really really want to create a plugin
page in rafaelgiz.com
i just don't have a bloody time but i
will do it
talking about plugins the one of the
biggest plugins i
wrote is the graphio
the graphical is a charting plugin for
raphael
because everybody wants to have charts
from raphael most
but anything else so graphically
charting
plugin let's take a peek
so
this is the pie chart drawn by
graphile nothing really exciting let's
to make really appreciate it we have to
look at the
the source code for this
okay pie chart
so
so here it comes so basically the align
to create
the pie chart is this
you create a you specify the coordinate
width and height and reduce
oh i mean x and y and radius and then
you put an array of the values
and it creates a pie chart for you
boring
okay it's yeah it's nice like it's nice
to have a pie chart
but what you really want to do is to add
some
you know events to the pie chart
so let's add event for the hawa
so when i hover the
sector this function will fire
and this function will run in the
context of the object which have
access to the sector so you could say
this.sector.rttr
i don't know stroke
black
something like let's do something useful
okay what i want i want to
create a drop here so
graphical also come not with just a
charting stuff but some helpful
methods like drop for example
and when i say drop i want to show like
a small pop-up
with the value of this particular
segment
so let's say okay i know the coordinates
of the center of this segment
in the context object this is max and
this
dot and y and
this dot value
it's already a bit more useful right
but not really totally correct so
let's uh hide it
so on mouse out i want actually to
remove it if it exists
that's a bit bit better right so you
could see what the actual values
for particular cases it's a bit a bit
not nice
looking i mean it's a bit boring looking
thing so let's
uh i actually know
the angle and angle knows the angle of
the
of the segment
yeah that's better right make it a bit
more funky
so you could make it as good like there
are lots of parameters there are lots of
different
things you could make it bigger if you
wish
to make it more visible you could
replace the
drop with i don't know pop up
pop doesn't have angles so we just kill
this
something like this you can do more
because it's
you control what's happening with mouse
over you could draw you could draw a
pop-up or you could actually access the
context of the page and draw something
using raphael you know highlight the
whole sigma and draw
arrow here draw something along
something change the hidden input field
in the different corner of the page
you decide what to do you handle the
events it's done for developers not for
psychic users right
so this is rafael
all the things are open source all the
things are free
i forgot to mention that but if you wish
to give me money i always
glad to have them uh
i did it for my free time and i like to
do this more and
everyone can draw with raphael nowadays
right in all browsers you don't need to
use flash
oh you have to slash when people are
saying raphael is a flash killer
i really glad to hear that but it's
flash is not about to be killed by
raphael or svg or html5
flash has lots of things to compete with
but if you adopt
what like if you have small project if
you have like again like the
sprout core google or yahoo pipes have
this you know
pipes connecting the elements you want
drag and drop around yeah you can go
with flash
you can write your own engine
in canvas use x canvas which is totally
wrong approach well canvas
in vml are very different things right
or you could use raphael for that
and don't invent the wheel well you
could invent everything that i invented
find all the rakes in the grass i found
good luck i mean
yeah it's fun it's painful but it's kind
of fun
or you could just use whatever i wrote
and it's open source you could
contribute you could make it better you
could
nobody contributed so far much there
were a couple of there were a couple of
patches but they were pretty much small
i'm working alone so the rafael team is
pretty
small and tight but we're working hard
to deliver the best results for you
and yeah
you can draw if you go in dubbed open
your mind
web is not rectangular anymore okay
make shapes make it make it rocks
thank you very much
thank you
any questions jesus yeah
is it possible to uh so you're trying to
save that for setting up the uh
the pages is it possible to resize the
page once you've set up
resize the paper yes
this part okay you may have that yeah
yeah
i just didn't go through all api because
it's yeah
there is yeah so i noticed on some of
the path
um when you were giving a floating point
you had a lot of significant digits
have you found like what the trade-off
is where you can still have
an svg image that scales pretty nicely
with the path
while trying to reduce the size of it
well what again your question so you had
some things where you're like go to this
x and this y and it was like you know
one point
and then three digits and so you had a
lot of significant figures could you
reduce that so your overall
path stream would be smaller but you
still have a high quality image
it depends it depends how big is your
path
so if you pass a 32 by 32 icon
it could be significant you could round
it to integers
you could see problems if you pass that
big
like 800 per 800 pixels you could round
to integer
nobody will notice the difference it
depends on the path
when i create the map of the australia
for
some real estate agents you ask me and i
have it as a demo
and that's very nice because you know
you know like you're going to real
estate agency you have like in your case
probably
us map and you say select you state and
you're hovering
and they either use flash or image map
or just looks dumb
right so with the raphael you could
avoid using flash
and make it works on ipad
or you could just make it easier to
implement because to use flash you have
to have flash developer in-house
if you have well awesome why why bother
with rafael but if you have just
javascript developer in-house
and don't have flash developer and you
need to create something
vectory rafael could be a choice so
for post really i rounded to one one
number
after dot it was good just integers was
a bit dodgy on the edges
one number was okay okay
yes
it's called monofil and this is called
eurofurence
it's two fonts which comes together it's
very nice
i like it
aside from some of the little
consultancies that you have to do with
bml in the
release is there anything that you
aren't able to do entirely
well rafael is basically is two scripts
bml and svg implementation
they are absolutely totally different
and don't share
anything pretty much
there are some generic functions like
parse color parse
path but in general they're way
different
there are a lot of things in svg which i
would like to implement by khan
because vml has lots of limitations the
gradients is the best example
in vml you can't have radial gradient on
anything but
ellipse it's very useful
and you can't that's it it's a bug
when you add radial gradients you have
rectangular gradients
if you understand what i mean it's not
actually radial
and even on the custom path it's
rectangular
so i don't know work around as soon as i
found i will put a page but so far i
have no
idea how to work around this so this is
limitation of raphael
the other limitation you can't specify
you could specify as many colors in
gradient
but you only could specify one opacity
at the end
you can specify multiple opacities in
sdg you can
and in every way you can in vml you
can't
it's just there's no even way it's not
it's not debug
just api doesn't allow you there no way
why
i don't know maybe it's useful for some
you know microsoft engineers maybe they
found it oh this will be useful for
people
i don't know
it's all thank you very much one more
time
you